du bist gestorben
[Musik]
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zurück
im mega projekt wird von der sonne
geblendet jetzt auf den server und mit
dabei ist der käfer lp lp mit philipp
ist hier dabei wir spielen heute
zusammen megaprojekt und du hast mir
erlaubt dass ich mit meinen sachen
zurück und dafür zehn werde nicht
erlaubt sondern die konfi hat es erlaubt
und wäre ja auch ihr habt ja dieser cdu
nicht schlafen
nee nich ich bleibe jetzt darauf was
machen du darfst deine rechte nicht
ausnutzen
da kriegst du auch wieder okay ich bin
ich bin quasi jetzt auf trap angewiesen
sein könnte sagen was er will und ich
wusste einfach zustimmen ich meine
sachen wieder das nicht möchte ist dann
aber ziemlich kommunen in sachen geben
was ich die letzten fehlenden gebohrt
haben das kann ich dir sogar zeigen hier
voll energie bronze lena ja ich bin
verlangsamt weil ich keine kontrolle
rüstung harten aber die charts station
die für dich sponsors mark und simon
danke erbaut von den akep nach einer
idee von bruder kann sie aber doch
schnell wird alles auch gerade was den
körper bei mir nicht mein chainsaw wird
nicht aufgeladen damit wirklich
aufgeladen und mein nasa am körper hast
wenn ich mir so langsam und quanta
neurosen hast du das tier wieder haben
januar kommt ich will aber nur der
quantum hose und den das portal obwohl
warte ich etwas hatte ich noch alles ja
der rest ist nicht so wichtig erst mal
hat man dieses loch portable also leute
ich weiß dass ich hatte viel mehr sachen
verloren
allerdings wissen wir nicht ob ich
irgendwie noch auf dem server war was
sich allerdings nicht wahr was glaube
ich auch der lok bestätigen kann oder ob
auch einige meinten dass meine user data
irgendwie fehlerhaft gelöscht
das war wobei voll fiel in letzter zeit
wenn die drahtlose und das ist bei mir
einfach so war jedenfalls habe ich dass
ich jetzt 30 level mengen diaz und so
was alles halt verloren aber ich habe
mir mal sagen haben und kriegst du die
voll aufgeladene quante hose die lehre
frank und moose aber dann stelle ich
nicht alt kurz auf die charts partner
ist die zehn sekunden voll das ist meine
war allerdings voll daher dass es gibt
damit die lehre alte richtige spur
das war nicht abgesprochen dann muss ich
machen das muss ich machen jetzt gehen
wir da ist das bein commission
denn ich schon bin ich zwar so dann kann
ich jetzt ändern
ich werde aufgeladen 50.000 wichtig da
man kann ja schon mal zeigen was ich
habe jetzt endlich nach hause
bei mir entsteht gerade auch so was
ähnliches wie ein haus das sich in
krümmel
nee das dann eben jung was ist der
himmel darauf alle machen allerdings ein
scheiß drauf so bestimmt spiel einmal
darstellen oder so
auch junge jetzt muss sich einer
lehrerin noch reingemacht ist nichts was
schnell ist einfach in meinen eigenen
ende fest nur in übrigens heute noch
einige dass man etwas nicht richtig
läuft weil darin die blackbox reingehen
das sehe ich auch gerade das heißt ich
muss den weg machen wo ich habe mir
überlegt was ich in dieser folge mache
jetzt habe ich ja schon ein bisschen das
haus werde ich auch weiter bauen aber
mein juli um etwa schweiz ist ja doch
sehr groß ich habe zwar alles da aber
ich werde mal warum die amerikaner bauen
damit ich ihn einfach mal haben ok weißt
du ob ich hey wieso legte sich dann
trotzdem nicht richtig 8 zuletzt
brauchen erstmal die ganzen anderen
sachen hier ganz andere sachen die
natürlich strom was ist das denn diese
steht da habe ich da den lauf wollte
solar entstehen ich frag wenn ich hier
durchlaufen da ich frag mich immer so
warum habe ich das gemacht warum habe
ich das jetzt gemacht immer so die
sachen die ich damals gemacht habe und
jetzt zwar nicht aber der hat ja noch
immer meine branche chillig typen wie
hast du das wär nichts mehr von mir dort
die sonne das ist abnormal heft die
warte ich eben den fragen zuwenden das
kann doch nicht wahr sein irgendwo mal
wieder geil ist das denn soll da bin ich
wieder menschen das ja nicht auszuhalten
alter ich war so hell ende gab es ein
kopf haben welchen kopf da zähle ich mal
aus und lass dich von mir kennen ich
will deinen kopf haben bitte hast du ein
viertel worte habe ich dann angefangen
hat kann meinen hut aber auch in woche 1
lasst nicht erst mal töten ja aber ich
habe sieben level ist sieben level kommt
ab und ließ simon nur eine sekunde
hinter das zu begreifen
ja okay stimmt was ich was soll
eigentlich in mainz
filmisch nur deswegen
was willst jetzt machen könnten ok wenn
junge getötet der mich wie ich aussehe
walter nein man darf nicht unter meiner
macht gesehen man darf nicht unter
meiner macht gesehen kommt die maske ab
so dass anders anordnen wenn solar helm
ist auch gedacht kannst du dann auch
noch eben wieder geben
nein ich habe nicht im modus verlassen
alter aber mein solar helfen das war mit
das wichtigste das ich immer deswegen
wurde ich auch nie aufgeladen stimmen
hast du das noch nicht ausgesprochen und
abgesprochen gewesen ja die sachen darf
ich mich zurückholte ich mal im inventar
hatte als ich gestorben bin und ich hab
ich habe sogar schon nur ca sind ja ja
nein das ist doch was verbirgt ja normal
willst du das ganze red box aus meiner
dingsda hinten
hier wo die produzieren stein der stein
wird durch die otto crafting tables zu
scrap gemacht und dann wird das weiter
zu spox und gemacht und die werden dann
hier durch mein ganzes war ich einfach
ein goldpreis über stoffe werden
aber ich frag mich wenn man ja scrap
boxen bald tut kostet kostet die 100
meter wesentlich weniger ja gesagt aber
wieso weil die produzieren energie oder
shrek boxen die erhören diesem programm
das geht schneller
graf ich jetzt noch einen links wir
haben natürlich nicht erst so weit weg
töte mich lustig wir haben erstmal
finden
ja geil da habe ich jetzt aber erstmal
drei level erfahrung drei level
erfahrungen ja doch das war richtig 3d
erfahrung auch man aber zum glück habe
ich meinen portal
ach mensch den keller muss ich auch mal
zu ende bauen hier stimmt ja klar ja
lass dich töten
nun ich habe nur weil 1
ich habe immer noch kein kopf was sind
das ja eigentlich für mauern alter noch
keinen kopf bei smoothies mauern und die
habe ich mir und den rest habe ich mir
aus wie im kleinen blöcken zusammen
gebaut hier also ich glaub ich muss doch
mal dein schwert benutzen
den rest hast du dir aus was
zusammengebracht gemeinde kann diese
blöcke zu diesen ein viertel nie ein 16
4 block man ehrlich der akura dieser
kleinen blöcke hier gegeben dass das ein
blog mit so einer
jetzt hat mich doch gilt oder nicht ja
aber ich habe immer noch keinen kopf
weil ich nur opa lines hat
wahrscheinlich die man bitte dein
schwert das habe ich doch nicht hier
wenn du mich damit auch eine nase
du hast halt zwei oder drei oder was bei
35 richtig 17 75 habe ich ja dann wäre
wäre es vielleicht sinnvoll wenn ich das
dann benutzt seine manpower und sogar
fünf haben bekommen jetzt mal ja solar
helm oder nicht weil die abmachung war
ich bekommen alle sachen wieder die ich
mir klar ich möchte erstmal mental malta
[Musik]
ja aber ich brauchte ein schwert dafür
hey ich brauche einen kaffee
du hast auf diesem elektrischen schwer
kein wunder dass das nicht geht
nein nein nein ich habe dass ich habe
schon mit dem anderen geschlagen so
warte jetzt sein
so sieht man daran wenn du nämlich den
kopf kriegt dann ist jeder spieler ein
one hit du warst kein wort auch ich
hatte vier herzens lässt man nur drei ab
mit jemand also ich habe keinen kopf im
inventar lass mich dich noch einmal
töten
ich habe immer noch kein flieger aus
betty verliert schon alle leben
vielleicht weil die wahrscheinlichkeit
ist daher wenn du mich hier schlägt aber
es gibt es geheime bass
ja ich weiß aber auch schon mal drauf
bist du alter er springt einfach runter
[Musik]
alles sterne pro tag steigen nicht
schlagen ist ok mode ein
du bist bei mir ich krieg einfach keinen
kopf ich bin zu blöd ist ein scheiß kopf
zu holen
die junge das lassen nein das kann nicht
sein ich bekomme einfach keinen kopf das
hat auch geklappt jetzt wollen wir
manchmal du hast nur wort 235 ja ich
muss einfach was fressen kurz glaube ich
gar nicht geil besucher jetzt mal höher
mal bitte kurz auf mich zu schlagen ich
töte ich jetzt einmal die ganze zeit bis
zum desktop ok auch keinen kopf gegen
die wand
mir ist klar dass ich fast keine rüstung
brauchen noch zwei herzen
möglich ja ich habe keine gute rüstung
ich habe die bibel schlechter rüst und
junge das ja dann nur noch ein herz
warte warte warte beim eine todeszone
warte das hast du angst hast du steine
verloren todeszone man habe ihn die
mutter von bist du dir sicher dass das
funktioniert ja nee ich krieg ein kopf
ist der junge wirklich keinen kopf
bekommen ich habe gar keinen kopf
bekommen sagte jetzt ich habe das nicht
direkt bay verbessern und schlafen weil
ich scheiße ich hier gelandet
da hab ich da jetzt aber ganz viel von
diesem wasser bis zu irgendeinem grund
schlug ein jetpack dabei abgaben es
dabei kommt nicht los
ich sehe nicht mal deinen namen
hey willst du alter eingesprungen bin
ich in irgend einem grundstück für was
siehst du denn so oder so teuer sind wie
wird der name wirklich auf der karte
angezeigt entfernt 100 meter klar doch
das kabel
damit folgen wir jetzt zwei steaks
runter und brauche ich einfach hoch ich
sehe dich einfach mal nicht auf mich
jetzt hier oder aus dem gröbsten raus
tut mir leid das ist ein gutes programm
kaputtmache aber wenn du ihr so eine
todesfalle beim ihr bowser müssen
irgendwie weil man kommt ja auch nur
sich die mittel raus bei ihm wichtige
station wo bist du alter verstehe nicht
wo bin ich da hinten wartet von wem ist
dass das grundstück jung da schreiben
jetzt mal böse schild hin
ich sehe hier grundstücke der mich noch
nie zuvor gesehen würde ich weiß gar
nicht wie alle gehören wohnt denn hier
gehen hier ist eine heftige einfach
heftig fc köln was ich mache jetzt
irgendwo ein portal auf dem mond und
hier in der mitte in dieses dings gebiet
war wirklich
schon sortiermaschine ist megageil alter
bei mojang wollte ich auch noch etwas
kaputt machen weil der mich jetzt
einfach so getötet hat so hast du sollst
solheim haben jetzt könnt ihr hier alle
sehen so wird der verdreckt jetzt auch
unter der maske
ich mache jetzt mal hier im portal in
das ist um teile maske davon dass die
ahs wird eingesammelt ja die welt geht
kaputt ich habe eine medaille gemacht
sind 1 am montag guck dir das an los ich
komme schon vorbei ich kenne eigentlich
schon aber was normal und in den westen
wo ich meine bord gegangen damals
verbrannt habe aus versehen open group
ist bereit mich an so ja ich sehe alles
weg gesagt jetzt hier alles weg gesagt
es wird gesaugt ob das nicht etwas weg
gesagt werden kann aber hier
da ich hab' ich hatte alles wieder an
mein vorbild schmerzt da ich sowieso
gehst da rein
wieso gehst du denn auch da rein ich
wollte ihn nicht schlagen und dann war
irgendwie der dann wollte ich ja
hochschule war das der hochschule wieder
fliegen
aber dann war schon der so zu starken
die mein leben gekommen und nachher ich
habe kämpfer getötet
du hattest klicks und jetzt hast du
sogar noch weniger als nichts
ja ich mache jetzt einfach hier alles
kaputt alter als er eingefangen
in der nächsten folge wenden wollen sie
nicht allzu lang machen schnell der
zombie wird eingezogen
doch nicht hat man überhaupt gesehen ach
so ja leute warten doch das portal weg
und zwar sind diese oft hier sehen
richtig schlagen wollte jetzt muss es
passen laut im moment naja mal die
kommentare was soll ich jetzt machen
womit soll ich anfangen
jetzt bin ich auch blut - 0 also also
ich kann der familie gefahren anders
noch mal ein paar sachen von mir geben
von mir auch noch mal
schließlich heißen bei der sache wieder
da noch mal danke ankämpft was ist
eigentlich meine solar helm
da kommen auch noch frachter dem mann
der am boden liegt und noch mal nach als
am rotenburger ja du bist ja gestorben
weil du einfach da rein gelaufen
low voltage da kommt einfach bei mir
vorbei da lass dich rein und da man ja
geworben
zusammen beziehen oder nicht in berlin
ich komme auch nicht mehr unser von hier
oben
[Musik]
alter wieso geht mein nano selber nicht
an junge der ist verhext
herrlich ist aber nichts passiert
junge warst du denn helbling ist der
spieltrieb an habe ich ording geworfen
ich habe sowieso nicht mehr hoch dann
leuchtet er sein grundstück auch nicht
mal aus ja die schuldigen dass ich keine
fackeln habt junge du läufst du passt
nicht zu mir
das kann nicht sein was nicht
hingeschmissen 100 eingeschmissen nicht
abbilden einmal gemacht das steht sogar
im chat iwf waren unter wasser geworfen
und wohin runter ja genau da wo ich
stand
vielleicht das von solar auch nicht
krieb allein ist kein solarium kelch
gibt mir ein ich hab den 100 prozentig
erstellt hundertprozentig mit mir
erwartet ob die passenden keller gelockt
ja egal alles von dir erstmal müssen
schwarzpulver
ich bin die mutter geworden ich komme
auch nicht mehr hoch ich muss mich kennt
vielleicht glauben ein gefühl für mich
okay du bist tot ich hier aber geworden
leute wie schreibt man keine kommentare
wie auch das cap gestorben
ich habe mir unter geworfen der liegt
hier aber einfach nicht wahrscheinlich
ist aufgegangen wir wissen mitgenommen
aber das kann sein sakko alter komme ich
töte die auch hier und noch ein paar
körper
das muss jetzt reichen
wo denn die füchse mein ego nee ich
hatte so einen silbernen was ist denn
silber sowieso nichts mehr als low
voltage weil ich schon ein video das ihr
fackeln gesetzt weil meine iglo ja dann
sind meine eis bleibt dir geschmolzen du
denn er macht ihr nur scheiße wird meine
ganzen plätze zum schmelzen als ob etwas
geschmolzen ist ja ja ja kommen wir
maniche globalen dann zeigen sie etwas
geschmolzen ist
minütlich etwas geschmolzen
ich komme nicht mehr hoch und ich suchen
wie ich mich immer töten kann damit ich
vor allem eine kiste kommt ohne meine
sachen zu verlieren da denkt man denkt
mal darüber nach das podest kommen
solche etwas geben von mir und ich würde
sagen wir warten erstmal ab und dann
nehmen wir irgendwie heute abend nochmal
auf und dann zeige ich dir dann gebe ich
dann was oder soja ich musste mich immer
so noch eine folge auch was du ja bei
mir kommt ja heute direkt hoch am 09
ja ich schau mal hier was ich mein kopf
morgen wie gesagt und ich schauen wir
was ich hier machen kann vielleicht
kriege ich ein kleines jetpack er selber
noch zustande
und ansonsten sehen wir uns einfach dann
beim nächsten mal
ich hoffe euch gefällt schreibt wie
gesagt den todes counter die kommentare
und was ich machen sollte ansonsten
bleibt geil und man sieht sich besonders
auch von meiner seite
[Musik]